- I'm the first episode!
- Look at that.
- Am I the first episode?
- Yeah, you will be.
- Oh, I’m the first. OK, cool.
- You're the premiere.
- OK, we premiering Taylor Rooks.
Taylor Rooks with me,
the Huncho, Episode 1.
The biggest, the biggest show ever.
- I was talking to my producers
about you coming in,
and I'm like, “You know what?
I guarantee he's gonna
have on at least two chains,
and they're gonna hit the mic.”
- Nah.
- And you have on how many today?
- I got on about six. But they cool.
It's the light kit today.
- What's the heavy kit?
- Oh, the big three Migos chain.
I gotta take that off as soon as
I come off the set, the stage, anything.
- Yeah. Is it, like, genuinely heavy?
- Yeah, it's crazy.
I wish I’d brought it.
I’d let you wear it, but I ain't bring it.
- Yeah. I mean, you have that on a lot.
I didn't realize it, like, was physically heavy.
Like, it weighed down your neck.
- Oh, it's a trophy, girl. It's a trophy now.
- It is.
- It's a trophy.
- So one thing that is always apparent to me
when I'm around people
who have substantially more money
than me is there is lingo
that I've never heard of. Like, I remember—
so my favorite song by the Migos
is “Time for Me.”
And in it you go, “There's five
watches plain, three flood.”
And I remember I said to you once—
- “What’s five—”[Laughing]
- I said—
- Five watches plain.
- “Five watches plain and three flood.”
I said, “What is flood?”
- Five watches plain, three flood.
I was just talking about the number of
watches I got, which is eight.
Five plain and three flooded out.
- OK, but so, flooded out?
- Yeah.
- Tell me what that means.
- Five watches plain, three flood.
Five plain watches, plain Jane,
meaning no ice.
- Uh huh.
And three flood mean all three of ‘em is flooded out
with ice.
See, this one is flooded, so.
- OK, so the flooded means
it has a bunch of...
- Diamonds.
- It's flooded with diamonds. It’s flooded with water.
It’s flooded with ice. You know?
- At one point in your life,
didn't have a bunch of money.
- Right.
- Now you do have a bunch of money.
- Mmhmm.
- And as you continue to grow,
like, definitions of things change, right?
So I'm sure when you were younger,
rich meant one thing.
But now rich probably means another thing.
Like, what does being rich mean to you now?
- Back in the day, rich meant, like,
my first $100,000.
I felt like I had a million dollars.
- Yeah.
- And today, rich is investments, wealth,
you know what I'm sayin’? Stocks
and putting your money up and
saving and not buying so much ice.
- Yeah. [Laughing]
- I had to get that out the way
first and then get to it.
- Yeah, so no—you're saying
you're not buying ice anymore.
That doesn't feel, that doesn’t feel true to me.
- I'm still buying ice.
I like to reward myself.
- Yeah.
- I feel like jewelry is just something
that helps me feel good.
It helps me thrive.
I like looking down
at my wrist, seeing it.
I came from nothing.
- Yeah.
- Or just looking down at my wrist
and seeing that it's some diamonds
where it could have been handcuffs
coming from the north, ya dig?
- Mmhmm.
- So, I just like buying ice.
- For the money, like, what about the money
is success for you now?
Like, what does that signify?
- I just wanna keep getting it
I just wanna keep getting money.
I wanna keep having fun.
I wanna keep my craft sharp.
I wanna keep my music good.
And the sky's the limit.
So if I want—if I'm on millions,
I wanna get billions.
- Yeah.
- You know? So
I most definitely
gotta get a B before I sit down.
- I know, it’s—you know, people
kind of underestimate the difference
between a million and a billion.
Like, they feel interchangeable.
- I mean—
- But they're not interchangeable.
Yeah, that's what,
that's what the strippers kinda say
They be counting to, like—
- Yeah.
- One or two o'clock in the afternoon
when we come in there, throw like $10,000
- Yeah?
- $20,000.
- [Laughing] Are you a Magic City
guy, a Cheetah guy, Onyx guy?
We talkin’ about the strip club now.
- I like, I like Allure.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Cuz I will say—so
obviously we are both from
Gwinnett County, Georgia.
- Yeah, shoutout the North.
- Yes, north of Atlanta.
So strip clubs are not weird to us.
- Nah, it’s not. It’s not. It’s
regular. It’s regular degular.
But you gotta go in there
and make sure you spend it.
Show love, you know what I'm sayin’?
So when you saw Lou Williams
leaves the bubble,
and at one point during his departure,
he was at Magic City,
what was—
- Oh, shit.
- [Both laughing]
- Do you remember that?
- I felt him cuz I used to do crazy
shit all type of nights, like,
just to get a plate of steak
tips and yellow rice,
you know what I'm sayin’?
That food is crazy there.
- Yeah.
- Even the lemon pepper wings.
But I like the steak tips
and the yellow rice.
That's my favorite dish,
- See, cuz that's the thing.
People thought he was lying when he said,
“No, no, I go to Magic City to eat.”
- Yeah. Their food is crazy.
- Yeah. Strip club food
is some of the best food.
- Yeah.
- So I know he has the Lemon Pepper
Lou wings there.
Do you have anything on a menu
anywhere in Atlanta?
- Oh, yeah, I do.
I got these cheesesteaks.
I mean, these Philly cheesesteak rolls.
And, like, they normally come out
big at Big Dave’s, you know what I’m sayin’?
But when you get ‘em small,
they call ‘em the Huncho Minis.
So I like ‘em. I like my little,
my little cheesesteak, Philly cheesesteaks,
nice and small. Like little cheesesteak
nuggets so you can just—
- Uh huh.
You gotta, you gotta eat ‘em like that.
- Bitin’, bussin’, beatin’, bunkin’, hittin’.
- I wanna talk a little bit more about,
you know, athletes in this space.
You know, Lou Williams also raps.
Have you ever heard any of his music?
- Mmhmm. Yeah, I heard Lou Will rap.
- Yeah.
- For sure.
- And one person who is always posting you
all’s music online is LeBron James.
- Mmhmm.
- How does that happen?
Like, how does LeBron become the guy
that gets Migos music first?
I feel like he gets everyone's
music first. But how does it happen?
- I feel like it's organic.
And then if we just feelin’ the vibe,
I know he need music just to—
sometimes he need that unreleased music
cuz he in the lab when nobody see it.
He in the lab when everybody
thinking that he on vacation.
So same way with music.
We got songs. We got records that in our phone.
Well, you might think we doin’ a show.
We got another hit ready to go.
So you just gotta get him
geared up like that
on some exclusive time.
- Mmhmm.
Cuz, you know, the joke
is he always posts it,
but everyone's like, “OK,
is he a music guy?”
Does he give you good
feedback on your music?
- Most definitely. I think so. For sure.
He told me about that “Straightenin’”
and went and got some straightenin’.
So, like, I'm just like, “Ight, cool.”
He know the objective. He get
the point, and I feel like
with music and sports,
I feel like we need that fuel.
We—you know what I’m sayin’?
Both, it’s both organically, like, married,
you know what I’m sayin’? Like, we wear, they wear jewelry.
They dress like us to hit,
before they hit the court, you know what I’m sayin’?
We wanna hoop like them,
you know what I'm sayin’? We make basketball
references, make bars and everything.
I feel like just their lifestyle
and our lifestyle go together equally.
So I feel like just music and them
just go together.
So taking their opinion really means something.
- Yeah.
- You know what I’m sayin’?
- So you send him “Straightenin’.”
- For sure
- He says?
Don't nothin’ get straightenin’
but straightenin’.
- That was the text? It just said, “Don't
nothin’ get straightenin’ but straightenin’.”
- I swear to God.
- And then you said?
- It's on.
- [Laughing]
And there was just an understanding
of what that meant.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, OK. I, as someone from the South,
heard that lyric and knew
exactly what you were trying to say.
But people seem to be very confused
about
“Don't get nothin’
straightenin’ but straightenin’.”
And then when people ask you, you say, “It means
don't nothin’ get straightenin’ but straightenin’.”
And then they're like, “Well,
what does that mean?”
So I want you to explain
what straightenin’ means without using
the words “Don't nothin’ get straightenin’ but straightenin’.”
- OK.
- So it’s like,
in basketball, say we lose a game.
We gotta play them multiple times.
The next time you come, you win.
You got straightenin’.
It's like get back.
It's kinda like not tryna fail,
you know what I'm sayin’?
Always straightening out the problem
before it become a bigger issue.
- Mmhmm.
- You know what I'm sayin’?
So you wanna straighten it before
bigger things happen. You get what I'm saying?
- Yeah, you were, you were like,
“I can't, I can't say it.”
But yes, it's like you have to—
- You wanna take care of it.
You know what I’m sayin’? You wanna handle it.
- I know another person, obviously,
who loves your music is Trae Young.
- Oh, yeah. My boy Ice.
- Yeah.
But you all have like—I feel like that's
one of your best friends.
- Yeah.
- Like, you guys are really close.
- Obviously it's because he plays in Atlanta.
You guys met there.
But tell me what it's like
just hangin’ out with Trae.
- He good, man. Just cool, and
he really just be chillin’.
He don't like to do too much.
- Yeah.
- He just be cool and tryna work.
And I feel like “Ice Tray the Gang”
has just become, like, people now
think, like, that is literally about him.
- Oh yeah, fasho. Fasho. Ice Tray
the Gang’s about my boy now, man.
- Yeah.
- It’s converted over to my dawg
He in the A. He in the A to stay,
and we proud of him.
And it's just, it's just a good feeling
when I see him out there,
you know what I’m sayin’? It's just—words
can't even explain it. It’s just,
that’s just my dawg.
So whenever he hoop, I be feelin’ like I'm hoopin’.
- Yeah.
- That’s it.
- Now, you and I both went
to a bunch of the Hawks playoffs games.
We were very excited
our team made it to the Eastern Conference Finals.
- Finally.
- Yes.
And we gonna do it again.
- Oh, yeah.
- I know
when the Hawks played the Sixers,
you bet some money
with, was it Meek or Michael Rubin?
- Meek. Meek. Meek.
You can't bet with Michael Rubin. That’s—
- Yeah, I mean, he's just—
- You can’t do that.
- That's a billionaire.
- No, no, you can’t do that.
- So how much did you win?
I won $10,000.
No, $20,000. $20,000.
- What's the most you've
bet on any sporting event?
- Mmm...lemme see.
Oh, $50,000 with Drake.
Georgia game, Georgia...
was it Georgia-Oklahoma?
I think it was Georgia-Oklahoma
Rose Bowl. And then we came back
with Georgia-Alabama and I lost.
We broke even.
- OK.
- Yeah, we broke even, but it was,
that was a good one.
- I also remember hearing that,
I guess on tour, you all played,
I don't know, it was one-on-one
or like five-on-five, whatever.
But you won that,
- Yeah, we played five-on-five.
That whole tour we
was supposed to play cuz
the tour was set up
like the NBA season.
I think it was, like, 80 days
or something like that.
So every, in every spot,
we had, like, a court,
but we started out playing a game.
It got so intense that we ain't even
play no more of those
the whole tour. It got too intense
We all had fun, though.
- Yeah.
- That was, that was the best
tour I ever been on.
That was the most fun time I had in my life.
- Yeah.
- Like, that shit was—
you can't even explain it. Like, basketball
with my dawgs, 80 days,
hittin’ the road,
playing the best music we play.
We all got hits together,
and we kept coming out on his set,
doing other songs
and doing all the songs we got.
It was just organic. It felt real good.
- Yeah.
And I know you made one of the half-court shots.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah. And I—Drake was
supposed to pay you for it.
But last I heard, he had never paid.
Did he end up paying?
- Nah, nah, nah, nah.
I ain’t get, I ain’t get straight.
I think we—no, he did
give me $10,000.
- OK.
- He did give me $10,000 on that. Yes, he did.
He paid me.
- Yeah. You did an interview with Angie,
and I remember he was late.
He hadn't paid up at that point.
- He was late. I was on him for a minute, too.
I was on him about my lil’ 10
- All right, so I wanna talk about
your music. Obviously “Culture III,”
huge hit. We were waiting a minute
for it to come out.
How do you know when
it's time to drop an album?
- It was way over time for “Culture III.”
It was just, like, the pandemic.
We was tryna figure out
what we wanted to do. And
I think we had the album right before it dropped.
We was gonna come the anniversary in 2020.
But then the pandemic hit.
That's what kinda, like,
threw everything off.
Then we had to, like, change the records
because, you know what I’m sayin’, like,
the timing was just,
was just crazy cuz, like, just speaking
the lyrics and the lyrics that you
talkin’ about was just so different
from what was going on in all the,
like, Black Lives Matter.
Things start coming up,
and it was just like, “All right, we gotta change it.
We gotta get right.
We gotta come back.
We gotta drop the Juice WRLD
record and talk about,
you know what I’m sayin’, real-life problems
with drugs. We gotta,
we gotta come back and drop ‘Vaccine.’”
And we had to, like, change it up
and go “Avalanche.”
We had to put the old-school feel with the,
with the new school and come in
and do our, do our shit on that.
It was just like, “All right, cool,
we gotta switch it up and drop this
and let the fans know we here to stay.”
And then we had to, like,
bring it back to, like, Day 1,
Day 1 Migos Northside shit
You feel what I'm sayin’?
I felt like we had to put all that in one
and then we had a chip on our shoulder,
so “Culture III” it was.
- There's this, like, challenge, I guess,
of making your album
always feel like it's of the time.
And that's kind of why you had to wait
a little bit for “Culture III” to work.
Is that accurate to say?
- Right. RIght. Right.
Not so much the time,
but just, like, just things was goin’ on.
It was just bad, right, for, like, music.
I feel like music wasn't even connecting,
you know what I'm sayin’, in the last year.
So when I—I put, like, a tweet out.
I was like, “When we drop, I feel like
the world gonna start rotating again.”
Like, the summer gonna start opening again.
And I feel like that’s what it did.
- So when it's times like this,
I'm sure you are inspired,
for lack of a better word, by certain things, right?
- Mmhmm.
- Things move you to write.
They inspire
what you're talking about in the music.
But is it harder or easier to be an artist, right,
and write songs in this past year-and-a-half?
- Yeah, it was really tough
cuz everything is sensitive right now,
you know what I’m sayin’? So you don't wanna,
you don't wanna almost speak your mind.
You wanna speak for the people
too, you know what I’m sayin’? So it's just,
um...which you just gotta
find the right pocket for it.
- Mmhmm.
- I think we haven't, we haven't did that yet,
but I think we gonna get our,
gonna get our moment.
We had a, we had a song called
“Crushing America,” but we didn't put it out.
- Why not?
- I don't know. We didn't—
I don't know. But it's, it’s hard.
- What's it about?
- It's crushing America
- What is—you know, you like,
you like explaining things
using the word of the thing you're explaining.
- Cuz I feel like
once we, once we say that, it’s the picture
that you already gotta paint.
- Yeah.
- You automatically just imagine
something. But it’s about, like, Takeoff came in
and was goin’ in about
just, like, what's goin’ on in the world.
And I came in and sung, like, some bars.
And Set came—it's like, it's hard.
- Yeah?
When is it—
- I’ll play it for you one day.
- When will it come out?
- I don’t know.
- There's certain rappers where you feel
like they coin certain things.
You know, people equate
T-Pain and Auto-Tune
Like, they say that is his invention.
What do you feel like
is the thing that Migos invented?
- The triplet flow, fasho.
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah. The triplet flow. Wasn’t nobody doin’ it
before we came in.
Right now everybody's doing it,
and it's a blessing.
- Yeah. Explain the triplet flow,
just if people don't know exactly
what you’re talking about.
- The triplet flow, the cadence, the
[Singing] flippin’ and whippin’ and—
You always want me to rap.
- I do.
- She want me to do it.
- And it's working!
- Nah, but the triplet—that’s the triplet flow, though, so.
- Yeah.
- That's what everybody love to this day.
And that's what you’re like,
people need to equate with the Migos
specifically.
- 2014, I was the most influential rapper, you know?
- Mm.
- And ever since then,
sky's the limit for me.
- Yeah.
Talk about why, like, you feel like
you were holding that influence
specifically at that time.
- Just the flow was different,
The swag was different.
Just some young rich n---as ready to go.
- Mmhmm.
I know David Banner said—I have the quote,
I wanna make sure I say it right—
that he has seen people
jack y’all’s style, jack the way you rap,
then go on TV and act like they didn't
rip you all off.
Do you agree with that?
- Yeah, most definitely.
They just don't wanna give credit.
You don't wanna,
you don't wanna come in sayin’,
you know what I’m sayin’, being new
and saying you took somebody’s style
or saying you got their style
or don't wanna say
you influenced by too many
young people cuz you don't know
how people’ll take it.
So.
- Yeah.
- It's all good.
- So, but why do you think that is?
Cuz I know there has
been different times
where you all have talked about, “OK, like,
we know this is ours.
We know we began this.”
Now, this person who maybe at the time had
a bigger platform is doing it.
And people are believing
that it is their style.
Like, how do you wrestle with kind of that
frustration of knowing that that's yours?
- Only person that can really, really
pretty much argue about the flow,
like, who started it or who kinda, like,
pushed the influence is Migos and Drake.
Because he came in and got on “Versace” with us.
- Yeah.
- So I feel like that
was the first time the world
all heard the flow, you know what I'm sayin’,
when it was Migos and Drake on a song, so.
And even with that,
like, even before that, I feel like
nobody else was using it.
Nobody else did it. Nobody else used it.
So now when they come out
and say different people
influenced and don't say the Migos,
I don’t understand how.
- Yeah.
- Cuz even the people
they naming that influenced them,
I know for a fact we influenced them too.
- Mmhmm.
Have rappers, like, come up to you
and talked about the influence
you've had on on their sound?
- Most definitely
- Yeah?
- Most definitely.
- When has that happened?
- You just gotta keep that to, you know, to myself.
- Yeah.
- You know what I’m sayin’? I don't wanna discredit
no artist, but they know.
They know I'm the realest n---a alive
- So when we think about,
let's call it the starting
five of Atlanta rappers, OK?
But you all are one. Like, I'm counting Migos
as one of those.
What's that starting five for you
when it comes to Atlanta rap?
- Atlanta rap?
- Mmhmm.
- Um, my starting five in Atlanta
gotta be Migos. Gucci.
2 Chainz.
We got one more?
- We have, what, Migos, Gucci, 2 Chainz. Two more.
- OK. Uh...that’s tough.
- There's so many.
I mean, cuz you also, you have T.I., you have—
- Gotta put Future.
- You have Andre 3000.
Or Outkast, if you wanna count that group as one.
- Put Future, Outkast and that’s—
- That’s five.
- One thing I really like about artists
is you feel like you know kind of
what place they were at in life
when certain albums came out.
Who do you think you were
for the first “Culture”
versus who you were for “Culture III”?
- I was just young, you know what I’m sayin’?
Not—just ready to work everywhere.
Not paying attention to, like,
just, like, the business side of music.
- Mmhmm.
- But, like, on—and just, like, life,
you know what I'm sayin’? So,
that's it.
- Yeah.
- I ain't give a f—I ain’t care about nothin’.
- You can cuss. It’s fine.
- I was just goin’ crazy.
I done cussed about five times already.
Well, yeah, but like, I was just,
I was just goin’ crazy on “Culture I.”
I was just like,
gas, on the gas, just ready to go, man.
- Mmhmm.
- Now, I'm just, like, real mental about my moves
and really think about it,
you know what I’m sayin’? That's it.
- Is there anything—like,
what were the advantages of, you know,
kind of that free-flowing style and attitude
that you had for “Culture I”?
- You never know what you get.
- Yeah.
- Like, when you don't give a fuck, it’s just like,
“Damn, I ain’t even know they was likin’ that.
I was just having fun.”
- Yeah.
- Like, even with “Versace,” we was havin’ fun.
We were having so much fun and laughing
and just, like, joking about the song
just being too many “Versaces,” just saying too many “Versaces.”
I was like, “Oh, my God.”
But they was like, "Hell nah. Record
that shit right now.”
So we recorded it, and it was up. It was over with.
- Someone said to me once that making it to
the top is not the
same as making it at the top.
- Whatchu mean?
- So, like, going to the top, right?
That journey to the top is different
than being at the top and staying there.
Do you agree that that's true?
- Nah.
- OK. Tell me why.
- Not for me. I just feel like once
I'm at the top, I still,
I gotta stay there, and I’ll do the same thing.
I do the same thing going to the top,
and I do the same thing at the top.
I'll never stop doing—like, I always
record five, six songs a day.
- Really?
- Like, after I leave here, I'm
fittin' to go record.
- Mmhmm.
- Like five, six more songs.
- I shoot videos on the go.
It’s just like remaining
just consistent, just staying
like, Bron said,
like his older self,
he know what he had to do
to his younger self cuz he already,
you know what I'm sayin’?
He put 'em together.
He putting it together mentally. And still
with that give-no-fuck mentality.
- Mmhmm.
- But you just know where to put it.
- Yeah.
What's something you haven't accomplished
musically that you want to accomplish?
- I most definitely wanna win
everything that all the musicians
before me won, like Grammys and,
you know, just VMAs.
I feel like we need
some of that, and that's it.
And just keep making good music,
more platinum records, more number ones.
- So I know you produce as well.
And I was talking to my friend
Gabe, who is somewhere—
he's right there—before this interview.
Just things that he'd wanna know about you.
And he was like, “OK.”
- So these Gabe questions.
- Yeah, this one is Gabe's question.
I liked it. I was like, “I'm gonna ask it.”
- All right, Gabe.
- He said, “OK, so if we gave Migos,
or if we gave Quavo and the Migos
this, like, old-school-type beat,
and he can put three people on it,
what beat would you choose,
like it's a sample,
what beat would you pick,
and who would the features be?”
- All old school?
- No, I think
new-school people? Old-school
people, too. Yes.
- OK, most definitely be a James Brown beat.
Any one of those beats cuz he most
definitely had a hip-hop sound.
- Mmhmm.
- Who would I get on it? Uhh...
I did so many songs with so many people.
I'd get Jay-Z on it.
I'd get Jay-Z, Kanye and, uh...
Kanye and Drake.
Jay-Z, Kanye and Drake.
All on one song.
- I'm sure that would be
an interesting song.
- Yep.
- For a variety of ways.
But, I mean, I think if
three of those people are on a song,
I don't really think it could go wrong.
- Can't lose.
- The final product
wouldn't go wrong. I don't know
about the creation of the song.
- Can't lose.
[Both laughing]
- But the final,
the final product, though.
- It would take a long time to come out,
but can't lose.
- It'd take a long time to come out, for sure.
But what's it sound like?
What's it sound like?
I'm not asking you to rap this time.
But just give me what
that song sounds like.
Cuz I think it's really interesting
that you produce.
But I don't feel like you talk about
the fact that you produce a lot.
- I don't know what it sound like.
I'm just, if I'm just the producer,
- Yeah.
- I'mma just cook the beat.
And I just want you to just lay this track.
I just want you to just go in.
You gotta come to the studio
See, you don't know a lot about music. You got to—
- Yeah. I don't know about the studio.
I'm a sports girl.
- You know about what it sounds like.
You listen to the music. You just say the words.
You gotta come and watch the—
Have you ever been to, like,
Benihana?
- Yes, of course.
- You know what I'm sayin’? The Bachi Bus?
They cook it in front of you.
So we cook it in front of you,
you know what I'm sayin'?
- Mmhmm.
- You can watch it.
And you can watch me
cook it in front of you.
- OK.
- We got your chicken, your steak,
your fried rice, extra egg,
no vegetables.
- OK. Stir fry?
- Got to cook it like it's stir fry.
- [Laughing]
- Again, that DJ Durel
gonna make the beat.
- Yeah.
- Oh, my God.
It's the season.
- So what is, OK, so talk about the studio.
Tell me the experience
of being in the studio with Quavo.
I've heard a bunch of things of what
it's like to be in the studio
with DJ Khaled. I hear it is just luxurious.
- Mm.
- He does whatever, and it's just a great time.
- Yeah, my—
- Studio with Quavo.
- No, my studio session is not like that at all.
- OK, I won't come no more.
No, I'm just kidding.
[Laughing] Tell me what it's like
- It's not like that at all.
It's just some good vibes.
All of us in there.
It's very cloudy, you know.
- OK.
- The room is very cloudy.
- Do you write better high?
- I just said the room is cloudy. I write—
- Do you write better when it's cloudy?
- I write better in the sky.
Yeah.
- OK.
- I write better in the sky.
- [Laughing]
- And I just make sure, like, I just make sure
that somebody got some crazy beats,
and then I'm just ready to go.
Like, when you see me, you'd be like,
“Damn, that shit crazy,”
cuz you really make a song in 25 minutes.
- Yeah.
- I make a song in like 25 minutes.
I only gotta do the first hook
and the verse.
- Mmhmm.
- You know, the rest of the boys
come in and go crazy.
- Yeah.
- And vice versa. They do the same.
- You were a quarterback in high school.
- Mmhmm.
- Shoutout to Berkmar.
- Yep. Shoutout to my gang. Berkmar.
- How good were you?
- I was aight. I was all right.
- Elaborate
- I did a couple, I held, broke a couple of records.
I still hold 'em a little bit.
I had fun. And left-handed.
I was good.
- Mmhmm.
- That was it.
- If you, if that was the thing
that you picked, right?
You were like, "What I wanna do
is play in the NFL." Or play
in the NBA. Whichever sport
you feel like is your best.
Is that something you feel like
you could have accomplished?
Was your talent there?
- Yeah, my talent was there.
My mind wasn't.
- Mmhmm.
- My talent was there for sure.
I could have did it if I wanted to,
but that's the only dream that
I feel like I didn't, I didn't, my goal,
you know what I'm saying, I feel like I didn't get.
And I think that's everybody's.
But I really,
I mastered everything I wanted to do,
and I just didn't do that.
That's it.
- It's so, it's so interesting, though,
because I feel like
a lot of rappers are like,
"I wish"—I'm not saying you wish—
but they say like, "I wish, like,
that was the thing I could do."
Like, be in the NBA or be in the NFL.
Like, what is—and yours is different
because you actually played,
and you were good
- Mmhmm.
- At those respective sports.
- But what is it
about those leagues that you're just like,
"This would have been so fun."
- I just, I don't think it's,
I don't think people feel like they wish.
I just feel like people
just think they'd, like,
could have just went a little bit harder
when they was a kid.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm sayin'?
And you remember them talks when they used
to be like, "You in 12th grade.
You gonna remember this. You gonna
wanna be back in high school again."
- Mmhmm.
- And everybody just take that for granted.
But just that.
I just feel like if you just had that same mentality
thinking when you got older,
you'd be all right.
But I don't wanna be in the league.
- Yeah.
- I'm OK.
- I think being a rapper, I actually have
had this conversation, like, a week ago.
I think being a rapper,
of all of the famous
occupations would be the best
and the most fun,
because I don't think rappers, like, rappers
can really do whatever they want.
- Mmhmm.
- You know what I mean?
Like, there's not, like an athlete,
there's some stuff,
like, you cannot do.
- Yeah, for sure.
- You just have, the world is yours.
Do you feel that way?
Like you have, like you're not as
restricted as really any other profession?
- Everybody's got responsibilities, you know?
- Yeah.
- You gotta be responsible.
But I do what I wanna do.
- Yeah.
- Cuz that's the
foundation I built.
- Yeah.
- But some people can't do what they wanna do.
Some rappers can't.
- Yeah.
- I do what I wanna do, though.
- And, also, the crazier things you do,
I feel like the better the songs are
because you were like rapping
about things that have actually
occurred at some point in your life.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It's crazy.
- So as we kind of, you know, wrap this up,
one of the reasons
I was really excited to have you on
—and you have been outstanding—
is I don't really know how many times
you have been able to just, like, talk
freely about yourself and your music.
I've never really seen
you do, like, a longform sit-down.
And I know that when people
are rappers, right,
there's Quavo, but
there also is, like, Quavious.
And I'm sure they intersect
in a bunch of different ways.
But what are some things
that you feel like have become
like your persona that we always see
that aren't who you are in private?
- I don't know.
- There's no—you're just always Quavo?
There's—that's not true.
- I don’t know.
I don't know.
- Are you as maybe
as boisterous as we would all think?
Are you always happy and having fun?
Like, what is, what are you like at home?
- I got energy.
- Always?
- I bring the energy always. Great energy.
- Yeah?
- That's all I'm here for.
- So nothing ever brings you down?
- Nope.
- Well, that is a very nice way
to live. Things bring me down.
I'mma hit you up next time
something brings me down
and maybe you'll give me some energy.
- If stuff bring you down, get off the ground.
I'm gonna have a nice little line for you. You’re gonna be
like, “When I get down, I'mma get off the ground.”
- Yes.
- “I ain't got time to be messing around.”
- Yeah. I've never had like a,
I've never had a—
And I'm not—
- You know what I'm sayin’?
When I'm feeling down, don't look down.
I don't got time to be messing around.
- Keep going.
- Don't be a clown.
- What else rhymes?
- Look around.
[Laughing]
- OK.
- Check your surrounds.
- Yes. Now, and I'm not, I am not saying I want this.
This is kind of like
a nightmare of mine.
I've never had, like, a name drop.
- I’mma send you a little voice memo.
- No, not that. I've never had like a name
drop in anything.
I had a name drop in a movie once,
but never a rap song.
And I'm like, I just feel like
that wouldn’t be great.
- Oh, OK. I gotcha.
I gotcha. I gotcha. I gotcha.
- But no, this was amazing.
- I gotcha.
- Thank you for your time.
Also, Quavo the actor.
I'm excited to see that movie whenever,
- Oh, yeah.
- Whenever it comes out.
- See, you didn't talk about none of the acting stuff.
- Yeah, you wanna plug it?
- Yeah.
- Tell me about Quavo the actor.
- Robert De Niro, Huncho, John Malkovich.
You know what I'm sayin’?
It's a movie called
“Wash Me in the River,” and I'm excited.
Was one of my first, you know,
movies like an action drama.
- Yeah?
- It's gonna take you through a roller coaster.
You’re gonna be sad, you're gonna be crying.
Then you gonna see me.
- Yeah.
Is this like, is it a pretty big, big role?
- Yes, it's a big role.
My boy, Coyote. I'm Coyote.
- How hard is it memorizing lines,
or did it come easy to you?
- Uhh, I was there for like a month,
I think. We was shooting
in Puerto Rico, and, um,
I just made sure I was just trying to, like,
be organic as possible.
Cuz they wouldn't tell you
when you kinda, like, mess up,
and I thought that was, like, a bad thing.
- Yeah.
- So I was like, they're not telling me what I was doing.
They're not telling me.
That means you doing some good because
if you mess it up, they'll
do a thousand takes
till they get it right.
- Mmhmm.
- So I was just, go in and just, like,
go in, like, twice or three times
and then just be done for the day.
And then they were telling me
I was killing it.
- That's great.
- So when I see the movie, I'mma
hopefully kill it.
- Yeah.
So I don't know how this works.
Will you get to see
at least some type of cut of it before?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- OK.
- I've seen cuts. I've seen cuts.
- Did you love it?
- I got chills.
- Oh, my gosh!
- I did a good job.
I did a good job.
- Wait. OK, so do we know,
when does this come out?
- I don't know when the date.
I don’t wanna be wrong, so.
- Yeah.
But I mean, like, you worked with Robert
De Niro on a movie. That's like—
- Yeah, that’s big.
- Pretty...no, that's huge.
- That's huge.
I had to tell my mama that one.
- Yeah. What did she say?
- She went crazy. "Damn, boy!" She went crazy.
- Do you, like, hit anyone up for acting tips?
Or you were just like,
“I'mma go in there and do this
and see what they tell me”?
- Nah. I just paid attention
to, like, Robert De Niro.
I paid attention to
Jack Huston. I was just watching them,
watch how serious they get right
before the camera, you know what I’m sayin’,
right before they say action, how
they, like, just try to channel something.
And I was just kinda
putting that together
and just trying to just calm down
and get, you know what I'm sayin’,
get the butterflies out
and just watch people in front of me.
I'm pretty good with that.
- Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
OK, I'm gonna be watching.
So, actor, rapper, producer.
Is there a fourth thing
we have to add to this in five years?
- No, you gotta add my athletic.
- Oh, yes.
- I'm an athlete, but I'm just not in a league.
- Yes, athlete. So is there a fifth thing?
- You don't gotta be in a league to be an athlete, right?
- Totally agree.
- OK, cool.
- Is there a fifth thing we're gonna add to this in five years?
- Fifth thing?
In five years?
- Yep.
- Shit. Billionaire.
- Billionaire. We're speaking it.
- Yeah.
- Gotta add that, gotta add that B.
- Fasho.
- Thank you. This was so much fun.
Thanks for coming.
- Thank you.